hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today
mention the question from one of our
readers Albert who had a question about
network marketing so wrote in saying
dear Evan thank you for the great
business ideas however I have a question
I'm in network marketing people always
say to me that network marketing doesn't
work please help me show ways that I can
succeed in network marketing improve the
people that it works so thanks for the
question Albert for those are you
watching who are in network marketing or
thinking about it if you want to prove
that it works the first way to do it is
go and do it yourself you know it's
building the network marketing business
is mostly about getting a downline right
getting people under you who can sell
usually don't make as much commission
yourself it's hard to build a real
network marketing business with just you
selling it's more about getting the
people in your downline in place but to
make that work you have to show that you
can actually go out and sell right it's
going to be hard for you to convince you
know 100 people that sign up in your
downline and actually be effective at
selling if you haven't gone out and done
it yourself is shown that it works right
so that's step one is you figuring out
the model you may not make a lot of
money going out and making these sales
you know the bigger money is in the
downline but to be able to get good
people in your downline it's going to
come from showing that you can make a
living from actually selling the
products so first step is actually doing
it yourself if you need help in getting
there I would try to find a mentor I try
to find somebody within your
organization maybe the person who
brought you in or maybe somebody above
them where there's some kind of
incentive for them to help you look at
how they've built their business what
success is a pad and try to model it and
use their strategies nothing to help
yourself but to help the people who come
in under you but that's the key because
if you don't have any success yourself
you could bring people into your
downline it's not about the number of
people in your downline it's more about
the quality you can sign people up but
they're not going to be high quality
people right you want people who are
seriously committed to it who want to
make this their full-time business and
and grow it and be massive
successful at it it's going to come from
people who really give it a good thought
right people who do their research
people who are committed to it and
somebody who's really good it's probably
not going to sign up for a program from
somebody who hasn't had any success with
it right so it's not about getting a
thousand people who never sell anything
for you you want the fewer people who
will actually go out and build something
out of it so if you were trying to
convince me for example to join the
network marketing business I'd really
want to look at it and see what have you
done what success if you had doing it so
first step is you got to go out and
prove it yourself you got to be able to
go out make sales and show that this is
a viable business that you know you're
excited about the next thing I'd say is
a lot of network marketing businesses
fail because the people aren't
passionate about the products you're
just trying to go out and make a buck
and that's that's always a terrible way
to try to start a business yes you want
to make money it's important right we're
not running charities here running the
business we have to feed our families we
got to put food on the table but the
main goal of running the business
shouldn't be just to make money you
should do something because you're
really passionate about it and you want
to help people so that's true of any
business not just network marketing so
you have to ask yourself are you really
passionate about this product or service
that you're selling through your network
marketing and if yes then a great way to
be able to sell is to tell your story
right why are you so excited about this
product that's being created are you
using it are you getting personal
benefits from it have you helped people
personally that you can really explain
their stories because that's the kind of
stuff that sells very well and if you're
behind it and you're excited about it
you're passionate about it that's going
to come through and people are going to
want to sign up for you if it's just
something here is an opportunity to make
money and you're not you know it's super
passion but the product or service it's
going to be hard to get customers on
board and it's going to be hard to get a
downline on board so it's not
necessarily anything wrong with network
marketing as a business model it's
making sure that you strongly believe in
the product or services being offered so
that when you're selling it it's a lot
more credible than otherwise would be
so those would be my you know first key
points if you want to show that it works
do it yourself you know build up a core
business if you need help doing that I'd
look to your upline and try to find the
mentor and try to learn how they did it
and share their stories but then also in
terms of work marketing in general you
want to make sure that you're really
passionate about it you believe in a
parking service you use it yourself
you've seen the benefits you can tell
your own personal stories about it
that's going to get people excited the
last book thing about no marketing is
people come in very often trying to make
a quick buck and they get all excited
about the pitch and whatever videos
you're showing them and all the
materials that come from head office but
it can be hard to make that first sale
and so you want to try to get them
involved and coach them and help them as
much as possible so that they can get to
that survival points they're making
their first sales or making a little bit
of money they have a taste they've
gotten beyond their comfort zone a
little bit and so I would invest more of
my time in trying to find really good
quality downline people and train them
and work with them and coach them and no
keep on top of them every week and touch
base with them and be a mentor and
support them as much as you can at least
until they get to the point of survival
where they've committed to this thing
just so that you don't keep churning out
really bad people who never go anywhere
with it and give it a try for a week and
say it's not for them and you're just
spinning your wheels so I'd focus on you
know fewer quantity of people higher
quality and then invest your time into
training them and making sure that they
really understand how to get this
business going and support them because
it's tough and if you've gone through it
you can relate right if you started this
business yourself and you went through
the first couple months and didn't make
a sale and then finally you made your
first sale and another one and then
another one that's a story you can
relate to them and they want to
hopefully emulate your success and do
something along the same lines for
themselves so hopefully that helps out
for a great question for those of you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up makes want to do
more for you and if you ever thought
about this video or network marketing or
if you have a question about your
business that you want me to answer
goofy leave in the comments section
below I always read those I love
come in and hope you'll be able to
answer question for you in the near
future so thank you and we'll see you on
the next episode